LIV WU: Hi everyone, welcome.
I'm Liv Wu on the Mountain
View Food Program team,
and welcome to you, Nancy.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Thank you.
LIV WU: Thank you for
being meeting at Google.
Nancy is actually a native
of Palo Alto-- Atherton.
She was born here.
But 25 years ago, she decided
to go explore sushi in Japan
with just a list of
things she wanted
to taste-- very primitive.
And just made her way
into restaurants and chefs
and tried to learn about them.
And on her way to
doing that, she
met a handsome, gangly,
tall Japanese farmer
and fell in love
and married him.
And he said, do you
want to live on a farm?
And she said yes.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: I said maybe.
Actually--
LIV WU: Actually, you did.
And the rest--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
--Let me think about it.
LIV WU: --Is history.
So, I was at the
farm, as I said.
It's a farm that
produces organic eggs.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Free-range eggs.
LIV WU: Free-range eggs.
And
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
And then food that we eat.
LIV WU: And everything that
they eat on the farm is eaten,
and Nancy has become
the person who
translates this tradition
for us in this book.
But really she's a heroine
among the Japanese, whom
like most rapidly
industrialized countries
are losing their
roots, their food
roots, their cultural
roots, and really
some incredibly delicious,
simple, and very helpful foods.
So, she is on
television in Japan
teaching the Japanese about
their food traditions.
It's this wonderful thing about
being the insider-outsider that
makes some of us the
translators of traditions.
Because we see the outside,
and we see the inside.
And she's taken that position.
And she's been the
premier supporter
of the artisanal organic
movement in Japan
and is their spokesperson.
Her book, "Japanese Farm
Food" won the IACP award--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
No, it was nominated.
Did not win, no.
LIV WU: I wanted you to win.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: Sorry!
LIV WU: International
Association--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
The French translation
is up for a Gourmand
of the world.
It has won the Gourmand award.
LIV WU: So highly regarded,
highly regarded book.
I think it's a really
wonderful book.
And Nancy, I leaf through
this, and there's really
almost no recipe with more
than five ingredients.
And you look at--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Farmers are busy people.
LIV WU: And you look at
the table of contents,
and it's small bites, pickles,
soybeans, noodles and rice,
vegetables, and seafood
is the last one.
Not a sexy list.
But this is real
food, good food.
And incredibly
delicious food if it's
seasoned with the soy
sauces and the misos
that are made artisanally
and still contain
all the probiotics in them.
So, she's really
the cook's cook.
The cook's author
and also really
the author of Japanese cooking.
The comeback of traditional
Japanese cooking.
What made you do
this unsexy thing?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: Well,
this is just the food we eat.
My husband was the
Japanese cook in the house.
And I did everything else,
because he's a great cook,
and so why would I just
jump into the kitchen
when we're busy?
I mean, jump into the
kitchen and do his food.
And we are busy.
We have small
businesses, and then we
started having children.
But I always had in mind I
was going to write cookbooks.
I thought first I was going
to do my food in Japan.
And then also I had
the title of the book
was going to be "When
Japanese Men Cook."
Because this has
actually been sort
of a compilation of
his food and my food
and-- because I like
salads and things.
But his approach to
food is really direct.
He actually learned to cook
from his grandmother, not
his mother.
And then later after college, he
went back to take over the farm
and work with his father.
And he don't like the
way his mom cooked,
and so he cooked
food every night.
He didn't like sugar in the
food, and he didn't like MSG.
And so he sort of
renewed the family food.
But then I started-- my
friends, my blogging friends,
David Lebovitz in
Paris, he said,
if you live on a
Japanese farm, you
should write a book about
the 100 easiest Japanese food
recipes.
And so I was like, OK, everyone
wants me to write this book,
so I'm going to write it.
And then it became
more and more my food.
And I came to love it even
more, because it was my taste.
It's the same food, but
like every cook has--
it's lighter than
my husband's food.
There's less salt, less soy
sauce or miso, and more green.
Because that's how I like to
eat, and I'm not a farmer.
Anyway, that's the story.
LIV WU: I find it's so out
there for you to-- it's
quite courageous,
it's unbelievable.
But the food, when you taste it,
using the artisanal ingredients
that she uses, is absolutely,
stunningly delicious.
It's crack an egg over rice,
pour soy sauce over it.
Really simple things.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Well, there's
this idea that Japanese food
is so specific and so codified
and so hard to approach.
But that's really not
how people eat every day.
Now, truly people eat
convenience store food
commonly.
That's a real big crisis.
And rice consumption's way down.
Tea, sake, all those
things are way down.
The Western diet is on the
rise, which is a problem.
60% of the people prefer
powdered dashi to making
their own with
katsuobushi kombu,
which is like the most
no-brainer stock to make,
and so--
LIV WU: Say what katsuobushi--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Kombu and katsuobushi-- kombu
is kelp.
And then katsuobushi is
simmered, smoked, dried bonito.
Skipjack tuna.
LIV WU: Skipjack
tuna that's dried.
And it dries almost
to the consistency
of a piece of wood, and--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Yeah, you inoculate it,
I mean most of the katsuobushi
is actually not inoculated,
it's the cheaper stuff that's--
but you inoculate it with some
spores and then it's dried
and fermented and dried
and fermented.
LIV WU: Absolute umami,
absolute flavor, right.
It's wonderful.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: It's
a very, very, very easy stock
to make.
It's not like making
stock from chicken bones,
you know, it takes a few hours.
You can do it in 15
minutes, 16 minutes.
So, ridiculous to use powdered.
LIV WU: So, this is a lady
who is into mold and spores.
At her house there
are jars of miso
being made, persimmon
vinegar in urns,
soy sauce made from scratch.
And she's totally into koji.
You want to explain
what koji is?
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Yeah, I'm
writing a book now
about preserving.
As a community, people used
to make natto together.
Not everybody, but there
were those communities
that were making natto together.
It's really hard to make these
big projects all by yourself,
because either you need
a really big family
or a local community.
And so, I got involved with
a miso making community
through one of my friends.
And he grows the soybeans.
And he actually steams them
up and he makes the koji.
And then another group
was making soy sauce,
and I jumped into that.
Along the way, there's
this koji, koji, koji.
This mysterious koji.
And koji-- and I've been
researching it and going
to the koji maker, and the koji
spore maker and the koji maker.
And the thing that's tricky is
that koji is the element that
makes fermentation
possible-- soy sauce amazake,
all of the saucy su say
so's, except for salt.
Miso, soy sauce, shochu-- all
of the Japanese key ingredients.
Katsuobushi is
slightly different,
but it's a koji relative.
And it's actually the spores
that used to live in the air.
And people would just capture
this wild spore fermentation.
And they would make koji.
So, koji is the
spore, and it's also--
confusingly also rice koji
is commonly called koji.
But it's actually called
rice koji in Japanese.
So, it's a little bit confusing.
That was why I didn't
quite understand it.
But there are these
spores that now it's
like a spore capturing
laboratory-- holds them in.
So sake people will
buy the spores.
Or the miso people will buy
the spores from their people,
from their spore
producing place.
But about five years ago,
this woman who had-- she's
like the seventh generation
of a koji producing shop.
And they were actually
buying the spores
and they were
inoculating the rice.
And then selling that inoculated
rice, which is kome-koji.
She discovered in
an Edo period book--
so we're talking more than
200 years ago-- this reference
to shio koji zuke.
So, there's this
huge boom in Japan
about using koji but
specifically shio-koji.
It just means you take
this rice-koji, which
you can buy from South
River for instance,
the miso place in Massachusetts.
And you add some
water, add some salt.
And every day you stir
it on your counter
for a week or 10 days.
And then it's this incredible
fermentation agent,
or it's good for meats, or
drizzle on the vegetables
or it's like a quick pickle.
And so there's this huge
boom in Japan about this,
just because of
this woman-- I just
went to visit her recently.
So koji was a
completely dying kind
of culture only used by the
specific, specific sake makers
or soy sauce makers.
And then now it's coming up.
And it's coming to America too.
I think you can find
if here and there.
Some of it's larger companies.
I don't know what's-- has
anybody ever bought it?
I don't know what's in it.
I haven't had a chance
to check the packaging.
But it should be
just-- the same thing.
You can make the same
mixture with soy sauce.
It's 300 grams of the
rice-koji to 200 cc of liquid.
And if it's salt water, you're
going to put 50 grams of salt
it.
But it's incredibly, incredibly,
delicious and easy to use.
A little non-sequitur.
LIV WU: Any reason-- common
universality between the West
rediscovering making sauerkraut,
making your kombucha,
making your own cheese-- why is
this mold culture coming back
to these--
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Well, this one
is because shio-koji-- the
salt koji or soy sauce koji,
shoyu-koji-- is so easy.
It's not even
fermentation in some way.
I mean it is fermentation, but
it's like the most no-brainer--
and it stays for a year
in your refrigerator.
And so it's not
like sauerkraut, you
got to eat it really quickly.
And pickles and
things like that.
So, any old anybody can have
it in their refrigerator
for a year.
And just like dollop
it on something,
or you marinate some meat in
it for a day and it's-- So,
it's the absolute
dead easiness of it.
And it's also very healthy
for the flora in your body.
But it's just she
discovered this really,
really, really easy great thing.
And so I think
that's what it is.
Because not everybody
can make pickles.
I am making a lot
of pickles more,
because my next
book's about that.
But realistically, I've got
a big, big wooden barrel
full of takuan-- daikon pickle--
and I left and I'm not sure
how it's going to
be when I come back
because it's going to warm up.
I'm only gone for a couple
of weeks, but still.
You got to deal
with all of this.
LIV WU: What was it like
teaching the Japanese how to--
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: I don't really
want to say-- I
don't like to say
that I'm teaching the Japanese.
I don't really-- I think
that through this-- I'm
filming with Fuji
Television-- it's
like going to the
katsuobushi guy
and they were really
excited about that segment.
Going to his place
and what is so damn,
cool about it and
it's so delicious
and this bowl of freshly
shaved katsuobushi
and dollop some miso
on some organic tea
and it's just so, so, so
easy and so, so, so great.
And 60% of the people don't
use katsuobushi, and then
the other, like, 39.999%
don't use the good stuff.
And so there's this
katsuobushi, and I shave it up.
I'm really bad at it.
My husband's really
good, of course.
Sometimes I can get
it right and then
I give it to the little
students in my school.
And then I say, who
wants katsuobushi?
Me!
And they're like, more!
More!
It's like you're
offering chocolate.
So that is what I'm really
excited about saying.
This is so great stuff.
Why don't we just use it?
Or we're going to the vinegar
maker and, by the way, 99.9%,
or maybe it's 80% of that one.
80%, 85% of the people
use this vinegar
that's on the supermarket shelf
that's made from ethyl alcohol.
And a little bit of
rice, by the way.
How delicious is that?
I mean I don't want to eat,
drink, or eat ethyl alcohol.
And so, these other vinegars
are actually made from sake.
Like organic sake, and they've
been doing it for 140 years.
So how cool is that?
And it's just people don't know.
So it's like saying,
hey, hey, hey!
You've got all these cool,
great things in Japan,
and there are 1,000
year old food traditions
that are being lost.
It's gone down to
this many people
are using the real stuff,
and that many people are
using the fake stuff.
It's not about-- I mean,
you can make a choice.
Like, if you want to buy the
cheaper one I don't care.
But at least know what's in it.
Like, if you go to buy a
big company's soy sauce
that's made from the
refuse from making
oil instead of real
soybeans, or you're
going to buy the
one with soybeans.
You know, I'd rather have
soybeans in my soy sauce.
But make the choice
with some knowledge.
But most people don't even know.
They just think, really?
That's what it's made from?
No idea.
LIV WU: You referenced
your school.
Just describe that for us.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: I have
a little immersion preschool
that I sort of modeled
after Peninsula School
in unincorporated Menlo Park.
I grew up near there and
it's kind of like a little-
it was in the day, I grew up in
the '60s-- like a free school.
It's still sort
of a free school.
I used to visit there
with my students.
And they cook for them, do
a lot of art and science,
like really hands-on stuff.
And they play
outside, and there are
tree houses and trees to climb.
And they're little preschoolers.
They start at two to
six, and then there's
elementary school kids.
And they speak only English.
LIV WU: So you started
it in your town?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
In my old house.
Yeah, we moved out,
and we renovated
my parents in-law's farmhouse.
And since it seemed
wasteful that I
had a little English
school and it just
seemed to make more sense
to have kids come everyday
and actually learn English,
rather than forgetting it
every week and coming
back to relearn, "do you
like," "can you,"
you know, those--
But the kids are really,
really, really into food.
And so every day
when they come in it
was like, "What's for
lunch today, Nancy?"
They're totally,
totally darling.
About that.
LIV WU: Most of us here
love Japanese food,
love to go to
Japanese restaurants,
or even maybe make
some of it at home.
How do we do what you're
saying we should do?
And how do we reproduce this?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: I
think that the first thing
is that you have to have
good building blocks.
So, I think the best
sourcing for Japanese food
is macrobiotic sites.
I use a place called Goldmine.
This nama shoyu that you can
buy at high end supermarkets
is our local soy
sauce, actually.
I know the people.
There's some in the
back that you can taste.
The misos, unfortunately, are
a little bit oxidized here.
So they're darker
than-- that's why
I brought some Japanese miso.
LIV WU: She's the ultimate mom
and the ultimate farmer's life.
She brought us miso to taste.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: I would have
brought more if I'd had time.
My suitcases were heavy.
One was full of food.
LIV WU: So please,
please taste them.
You'll be amazed
at the difference
between the commercial--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: And
our friends grow for them,
and it's organic.
So, I think that
getting good soy sauce,
good miso, good salt-- I
think that the Trapani salt is
a good substitute for-- I
use Noto salt from Japan.
Trapani salt is really similar.
And it's clear, kind of briny.
And then good fish,
good vegetables.
I mean the easiest thing is
like this steamed and sake fish.
You can't overcook it.
And the vegetables,
the vegetables,
go to the farmer's market,
fish market, and you're done.
But I wouldn't
start with-- I can't
say the name of the
company-- I wouldn't start
with large company
type of ingredients.
Because like the vinegars will
be way, way, way too vinegary.
And the soy sauce won't have
that taste that you need.
LIV WU: The soy sauce
back there is amazing.
It's made by artisanal methods.
It's live, organic--
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: And you saw it.
LIV WU: --Not pasteurized.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Two years in the barrel.
LIV WU: Yeah.
And it's really wonderful.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
So, the interesting thing
is since I've been making my
own soy sauce with my friends--
and I have a barrel at my house.
They're fermenting it in poly
barrels, polyurethane I think.
Is that the word?
When you make it at
home it's a lot thinner
than commercial soy sauce.
Even this.
And so I think that as time
went on-- in farm families
you just put soy sauce
on the vegetables.
Like, if you boil
some vegetables,
you put some soy sauce
on and katsuobushi.
Sometimes dashi to thin it out.
But I think the
town people do more
of adding the stock to--
the dashi to the soy sauce
because it was too overpowering.
Because it's commercial.
That's my new theory.
LIV WU: And dashi is stock.
[INTERPOSING VOICES] What's
a meal we can make out
of some recipes in this book?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Well, like I said,
I think that the easiest
things are the steamed fishes.
I'm partial to raw fish, but you
have to be careful and get it--
you have to ask the fishmonger
if you can eat it raw.
Not necessarily eaten
raw-- you put kombu on it
and a little salt to suck
out some of the moisture.
Or salt and vinegar.
There's various treatments,
it's pretty common.
And nabe, the hot spot.
Hot pot is really a misnomer.
It used to be called
"one pot," and then
it changed vogue to be hot pot.
But really nabe is such
an easy word to say.
I'm trying to get that
into the vernacular.
But nabes are--
you just put a pot
with some kombu and some water.
And then you start adding
vegetables and tofu
if you have it and some sort of
protein if you're into protein.
LIV WU: It's kind of
a-- [INTERPOSING VOICES]
fondue pot.
Do your kids, do your
sons eat dad's food
more or mom's food more?
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Well, they
eat whatever is on the
table, I'll tell you that.
Recently, they're 22, 19, 17
so they like more hearty food.
And so they like
my Mexican food,
but then they like his
curry rice, whatever.
And they all cook, but if
you gave them their druthers
they'd have me or
my husband cook.
They all worked at Soba
restaurant, a friend's place
when they were 13 to 16.
We home-schooled.
LIV WU: And I take it
you eat with the seasons,
if you're eating on the farm.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Oh yeah, yeah.
LIV WU: What's the
most nostalgic season?
What's the most
abundant season for you?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: Summer.
LIV WU: And what are
you harvesting then?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Summer-- tomatoes
don't grow so well
because of the humidity.
But we have tomatoes,
cherry tomatoes do better.
Tomatoes and peppers and
hot peppers and eggplant,
cucumbers.
Lettuce doesn't grow
well in the summer.
Neither does cilantro, so
that's sort of spring stuff.
And then we also
buy from friends.
Because we have
parties or need more.
And that's also
the busiest time,
because the weeds grow
about a foot a day.
Maybe it's a foot a week.
LIV WU: I guess we're not going
to see those beautiful slides,
but tell us about some of them.
As if they were up there.
Are the slides about
making soy sauce?
What are important images for
us to look for in the book?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Oh, in the book--
because soy sauce is after,
soy sauce is for the next book.
In the book what I
tried to portray,
or what I wanted to write
about, what that Japan is not
this inaccessible, mysterious,
hard to understand place.
That the relationships are
very direct and normal.
And you can hug
somebody if you want.
And Japanese people are
just the same as you and I.
And that it was just
this place full of-- I'm
really into antiques
and farm stuff.
So it's just this place with so
much-- there's so much fabric.
I mean, not just
this kind of fabric,
it's the fabric of
life-- of farm life--
is so rich and
interesting and direct.
And it's not a way
of life that will---
Foreigners or Tokyoites are
kind of in the same boat.
They don't really know
much about this life.
And I have a lot of Tokyo
people come out for filming
or whatever.
And it's like the
first time maybe
they've been in a farmhouse.
LIV WU: So the revival
is happening in Japan.
People are rediscovering
authentic, traditional cuisine?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Yeah, some people
are going back to
the-- and leaving.
I forget what they
call it, U-turn or no--
there's all these
words, these slogans.
But people are leaving
the city to come back.
Not in droves, but
come to mountain towns
and have a little bit
better way of life.
Less money, but maybe better
place to raise up your kids.
What's happening
actually in Japan,
which is more interesting is
that the Japanese government
is working to brand Japan.
And so there's a
lot of-- and so it's
going to be a really
good time to go visit
Japan in the next
couple of years
because they're
identifying local areas--
and I'm involved in
several projects with this.
They're disseminating
money for projects
to identify local areas that
have cool things happening.
And like food, or
artisanal, arts,
crafts, all sorts of things.
It's not just about food.
And it will be
something like, do they
want to send that stuff
abroad or to Tokyo?
Or they want to get people
to come to visit that area.
And also because
of the-- and that's
one arm-- but another thing has
changed in Japan the last 10
years.
10 years ago, people did not
have computers in their house.
Did not.
And so from 10 years
ago, people started
having-- I mean
they had phones that
worked on the internet
sooner than they
had computers in their house.
And so nowadays, I'd say
most people have computers.
But not everybody.
Like my friend--
restaurant friend--
he doesn't have a website
and he doesn't even
know how to use email.
The farmers-- again, not all,
but somebody in their family
is going to know how
to use the computer,
and somehow they can Google it
and they can find this place.
And so all of a sudden now,
all those outlying areas
are connected somehow
with internet access.
Like, even if they don't have
a page you can Google them
and you can find somebody's
written about them.
And then there's a phone number
there, and you can call them.
And you can order their stuff.
Or you can go visit them.
So that's what's really changed.
That's something I
really-- So, that's why
I like-- somebody was talking
about the market in San
Francisco, Nijiya.
They're finding more artisanal
products, food products,
in Japan that used to
be just so remote you
couldn't find their information.
So now they can find them
and get them and actually
get them on the shelves here.
And same thing in Japan,
because we have this delivery
system that you could
order something,
send it off 6 o'clock
one night, and you
can get it the next morning,
because it goes all night.
So I was kind of pessimistic
at the end of this book.
But I'm very optimistic now.
It's changing.
LIV WU: Great.
And the reception in
the West to this book
has been unbelievable.
Did you expect that?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Um, I guess I hoped.
I thought it would.
The publishers
did not expect it.
LIV WU: It's beautiful.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: But
the one thing I did not expect
was how much the book spoke
to Japanese-Americans.
I had not anticipated that.
I have people come up to me
and say that I bought five
for my family, and this
was how our family used
to live before my family
came in the teens,
and we've lost all
these food traditions
because there was no
history of writing down
recipes in Japanese families.
So that has been maybe
the most impactful for me.
But it also has had a
big effect on Japanese.
It's just it's a
difficult book to publish
in Japan, because cookbooks
are like $10 throwaways.
It's unheard of to
have a book like that.
So, we'll see.
It's been published in French.
Maybe Dutch.
LIV WU: Congratulations.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Thank you.
LIV WU: Anything
else you want to add?
And then I'm going to throw
it to the floor for questions.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: The only thing
is that I really
can't emphasize enough
how I would recommend
sourcing the ingredients
from macrobiotic sites.
Because I visited a bunch of the
supermarkets in the area and I
found that the amount of
good ingredients was so slim.
And so much of the
ingredients have MSG in it.
And all of the preferred
pickles are all full of MSG,
as they are in Japan.
So if you don't mind
MSG that's fine.
But it speaks to lack
of flavor otherwise.
And salt pickles and things
like that are so easy to make.
Or soy sauce.
LIV WU: And I will
add a question
on to that, which is
there's this American love
affair with sushi and sashimi,
which is where you began.
How do you nudge
yourself off that?
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: The thing
is, though, I have to say
that sushi is a culture.
And so, it's actually like
a rich man's drinking spot.
And nowadays, most people have
never been to a real sushiya.
And we have sushi-- we do
handheld sushi dinners at home,
getting fish from
the fish market.
But the whole feeling of going
to a really good sushi shop
and having the master who
spent years and years and years
and years learning
his craft-- I'm
friends with Jiro-san's
editor, and so I've
had the opportunity of
coming four times, which
is very lucky, never paying.
And just that experience of
being in that-- it's not just
the food, it's the whole thing.
And that's why I went to Japan.
It's that feeling of sitting
down that's like (EXHALES).
And then you get
this beautiful food.
It's not just about sushi
in the round for me.
So it's a really complicated
type of relationship.
But it's also--
real sushi in Japan
is very expensive--
can be very expensive.
LIV WU: Somebody
at our lunch table
was saying her grandmother
used to tell her mother
ikura-- salmon roe--
is bad for you.
And later on she learned it
was because it was expensive.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
It's because it's
really hard to get
it out of the sacs.
It takes time.
LIV WU: She told her kid
there was bad for them
so she wouldn't have
to buy it for them.
So, with that, are you
OK if we open it up
to questions from the floor?
I think we'd probably get
more interesting discussion.
AUDIENCE: You briefly
mentioned about koji.
It keeps for one year.
What happens after one year.
And then, you know,
do you discard it,
or do you keep adding to it?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
No, no, no, no, no.
It's not koji.
Shio koji or shoyu koji.
OK?
So, you could probably
use it for marinating
meat or something.
But I don't know the
scientific part of it,
so I can find out from my pal.
But after a year it's probably
going to lose its fermentation
properties or some of the--
AUDIENCE: If it does
ferment anymore,
that means the food is
going to start going bad.
If it doesn't
ferment anymore, that
means the food is going to
start going bad at that point.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Oh, I wouldn't
say it's going to go
bad, because you still
have salt or soy sauce in it.
Because salt alone or
soy sauce alone is-- it's
not like you leave them on.
Meat's the only thing
that you marinate
for more than-- I mean a
vegetable is like 10 minutes.
Like for zucchini, half
an hour or something.
It's not a really long-- we're
not talking long ferments.
It's a quick pickling thing.
Or for me it's
like if you salt it
or if you soak it in soy sauce.
If you do it for half a
day, it takes up more.
But as it soaks it has
more tenderizing properties
and more healthful properties.
You don't add to
it because you're
going to use it more than
a year, that's for sure.
AUDIENCE: Because I was
associating with miso.
And miso has koji in it.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Yeah, but miso never goes bad.
AUDIENCE: But then
white miso is not
suppose to keep as long
as it-- white miso?
Doesn't keep as long as
the other kind of miso.
So I was wondering why.
And then I do have
some miso in the fridge
that I brought back from Japan.
I was wondering if I
should throw it away.
I heard that I can freeze it.
But then if you freeze
it, what happens to koji?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: The
koji dies in the freezer.
There's no more good
qualities for koji.
It doesn't mean it's bad.
But the white miso
shouldn't go bad.
I mean, white miso
is white because it
has a lot more
koji in it, and it
has a really short
fermentation period.
So it can be done
really quickly,
because it's a higher
concentration of koji
to soybeans.
But miso will never go bad.
I'm not sure about--
depends on the miso.
The white miso, I don't use it.
It just gets darker, or you
scrape off the darkened place.
But I'm not American.
We keep things.
My husband makes me sift the
flour and take the bugs out,
so you know.
I was horrified,
but you know-- more
horrified about him getting mad.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of illegal activities.
In Japan it's illegal
to brew anything
with more than 1% alcohol.
And are there things that
you can create in the States
because we don't have that law?
Any traditional foods that
involve some amount of alcohol
that you can't create in Japan?
And where did you get
the brewer's yeast?
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Brewer's yeast.
Oh, not brewer's yeast.
You mean koji?
AUDIENCE: No, because
first you have
to convert it to
sugar with koji,
and then ferment it to alcohol
with brewer's yeast, right?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: No.
I only know from-- well I
visited the vinegar people
making sake.
There's no brewer's
yeast in sake.
But they don't add yeast--
let me find out from the book.
I have a minute.
But my husband makes doboroku.
That's what you're
talking about.
And that's koji
plus rice and water.
And I am going to put
it in the next book.
But basically, I think
you can find that recipe.
And you half steam the rice.
You can't cook it all the way.
And then all the rice has to
cool down before you add koji.
And you want a pot.
AUDIENCE: That would be a fun
thing to put in your book,
then.
You could put a
disclaimer, you can only
make this outside of Japan.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: I know, I
have to be careful
when I talk on TV too.
I mentioned it in
the last book too.
AUDIENCE: I've
always been curious
about the possibility
of making miso at home,
and I was wondering
if you could comment
on the ease or difficulty
of what's involved.
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Super easy.
Really, really easy.
I mean actually, this woman,
the koji lady, she-- Hi Claire.
I didn't see you.
--she made miso.
It wasn't fermented at
all, but she made miso
on the studio set with
a pressure cooker.
We steam the soybeans, you
know, with a pressure cooker.
And then she added
the koji and salt.
And basically, it's a
super simple operation.
And the Shurtleff's
book, "The Book of Miso,"
it's really long.
I mean it's really good thing.
I felt like it was a
little bit intimidating,
but I only leafed through it.
But doing it, it's
basically steamed soybeans
that you smash up.
I grind them.
Some people have a
grinding machine.
And then you add in salt.
You can make the rice koji from
the great South River people.
And then a little
bit of miso that's
been softened with water, like
a really super, super, thin miso
soup as a inoculation.
And then you just
pack it in a pot
and as the summer
goes hotter you
stir it every once in awhile.
But really, it's
as simple as that.
So that's why I'm trying
to get my book out
by February at least.
So people still make it.
AUDIENCE: I was also wondering--
today is the third anniversary
of the typhoon and Fukushima--
if you had any thoughts on food
safety, concerns--
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Food safety
I would not worry about
because, I mean especially
if you live here, because the
Japanese government does not
want to have any trouble
with the US government.
And in fact, they told
the outlying governments
a lot sooner than they
told their own people
that there was a big emission.
As for the nuclear
situation, nothing's changed
and there's massive,
massive, massive amounts
of water-- nuclear
waste water-- that's
going into the groundwater
into the Pacific Ocean.
And they're no closer
to finding a-- I mean,
I don't know if a
solution exists,
but it's pretty horrible.
And we just--
we're fairly close.
167 miles.
I think they'll just keep
flushing it for an eternity.
I can't imagine what
they're going to do.
The news people
talk about that too.
They're just like, oh yeah.
What's the point of talking
about it kind of thing.
But food, there's
another ocean over there.
The Japanese Sea is
where we get our fish.
It's really a sad
situation, heartbreaking.
AUDIENCE: Because I
think a lot of them
are grown in
hydroponic conditions--
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Yeah, that's a big thing now.
AUDIENCE: So they are very
pretty, and they're very sweet.
They just don't
have depth of flavor
that we have here in
the States, actually.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Tokyo has bad vegetables.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I found the
vegetables better in the US.
Even though they
don't look as nice.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: I think
the chef's really concentrate
on-- they're very
good about fish.
So you can get good fish
pretty much anywhere,
but it's really hard for
me to eat in Tokyo now,
because I'm really
into vegetables,
and it's like a
zero on the plate.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
How difficult is the soy sauce
process, or making soy sauce?
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Yeah, soy sauce.
We so far have a small
soy sauce place in Nagano
who takes my friend
who grows the beans,
and he grows the wheat.
And then they inoculate it
with-- they put the koji in,
and then we rush up with
air, we put the salt on.
But basically, you mix
in steamed soybeans
with wheat that's been
inoculated with koji,
and you add salt and water.
And you stick it in a
barrel of some kind,
and let it sit for
a year to two years.
I'm making fish sauce now.
We'll see.
It will take a year and a half.
Put the salt-- 17%
salt-- with mashed up,
chopped up fish in a pot.
Wait a year and a half.
We'll see.
That Japanese fish sauce, you
should start looking for that.
It's really hard to find here,
but it is really, really,
really good.
You tasted some at
my house, right?
I have some macro fish sauce
from the Stubborn Mother
in the Wajima market.
No label, it's a
[? pet ?] bottle.
And it is just so good.
But she puts not just
guts and heads in.
She puts in the meat
of the fish too.
Helps it be sweeter.
But it kicks ass on
all other fish sauces.
Totally.
LIV WU: Yes, Peter.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU: Um,
there's three names actually.
The northern place,
Akita, calls it Shottsuru,
and it's usually
made from sandfish
or sometimes squid or sardines.
And then the
Ishikawa prefecture,
which is where the
Noto Peninsula is,
they call it Ishiri or Ishiru.
And they have-- I mean, the
whole culture down there
is all about that.
And that's what really
was fascinating for me.
My husband had used it before.
I always had it at home,
and I used it sometimes.
And I put a little
bit in the book.
But once I went to the
maker, and I talked to them,
and all these different
ways to use it.
They call it [? kakshaji, ?]
just a little
bit it of hidden taste.
So I put it in, just choo.
You don't want to
taste it so much.
It's really good with
like a thin pickly thing.
And I put it in
Western daubes or stew.
Or I put it in fried rice,
just choo, a little bit.
LIV WU: The secret umami hit.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
So it's a hidden taste.
All these areas are big
on the hidden taste.
Like, Katsubishi area, they
put katsuobushi on everything.
It's not hidden taste.
It's like every single thing.
They put it on the raw
egg on rice and soy sauce,
katsuobushi too.
The vinegar people, they
put it in everything.
Just as a choo.
LIV WU: So I'm coming
to the conclusion
that one of the foundational
secrets of cooking
and controlling flavor is
dealing with fermentation.
Or, if you want to
put it another way,
is controlling rot.
And that really is.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Sandor Katz said,
don't be afraid of the mold.
So sometimes with my pickles I
got something going on on them,
and I just take it off.
Same thing when I do
sauerkraut-- and also,
not being afraid of
getting rid of the plastic.
So I always made my
sauerkraut in a plastic bag.
We have pickling bags, they're
food-grade pickling bags.
But I'm moving on
to all of my-- I
have this cabbage ready
to go before I left,
and I didn't have time to do
it, so I stick it in the fridge.
Hopefully, I can try it.
But I'm going to try the
sauerkraut without the pickling
bag.
But just put it in
a wooden barrel,
and put some muslin on top.
And I think the
plastic promotes mold.
I'm very unscientific
about my pickling.
AUDIENCE: What's the
deal about natto?
NANCY SINGLETON
HACHISU: Oh, natto?
Good natto is really good.
I've made it-- I
had an experiment,
and I made it-- natto naturally
ferments in the rice straw.
And I tried it
within the rice straw
or inoculating it with the
natto-kin, the natto powder
spores.
Or you can take some natto
slime and add some warm water
and harvest.
So, I got it from the Yamaki--
my people, got some very natto
and I made a little solution,
inoculated the beans with that.
They all tasted
good, but the thing
is I should have been
more scientific about it.
I should have put it in a
controlled heat environment.
It was a very cool few
days in the summer.
And so I decided I'd
put it in the car.
And then one day I
woke up in the morning.
It was like the heat
arc had gone way up.
But it was delicious.
The best one was the
one in the straw.
They weren't slimy,
but they tasted good.
And so, I still have
to get back into it.
But there's a method where
you put it in a big hole
in the ground and
you put it in straw
in a big hole in the ground,
and you pour hot water on it.
Then you pack it with earth.
I'm going to do that next.
My friend described it.
Yeah, good natto is really good.
But it should be good natto.
Can't find good natto very
much in Japan anymore.
It's all-- none of it's
organic, except for our friends.
Not much of it.
LIV WU: So, please
taste the misos
and the soy sauce in the back
that Nancy brought for us.
And thank you so much
for coming to Google.
NANCY SINGLETON HACHISU:
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]